this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
I just I just debunked conspiracies Sam
believes everything's a conspiracy wait
you
you debunk them or you promote and I
debunk them got it got it okay
right well it's tough when you're
talking like a flat earther if they know
their [__] yeah arguing people that's
what's fine and you don't you're like
it's round like yeah come on dude
they're drowned they're like yeah but if
you and when they're like have their
black belt and arguing Flat Earth I
don't know if you've tried it they've
steamroll through you well that's a
problem you also are arguing on the same
plane and now that there's facts and no
the fundamental difference between a
conspiracy theorist myself is this
conspiracy theorists actually believe
there's a small group of people that
have the ability to control literally
everything
yes and place your head and aren't even
so so the problem with anything is that
people have different points of view go
to a barber shop and there'll be six
different points of view you know it's
it that human beings aren't like that
everybody has a different way to solve a
problem everybody sees a different
problem everybody believes this isn't a
problem this is a problem how it affects
them the FED has their idea what to do
with inflation and Congress has their
idea of what's politically expedient
right it goes on and on so the idea that
there's this small group of bankers and
by the way most conspiracy theories
usually have the Jews at the top the
globalists the globalists yeah the
globalist which is which is code for
Jews I mean you know but but if you look
at it at the end of the day you're like
you think that they and by the way
they're in the Vatican the Buckingham
Palace sure but the Vatican Buckingham
Palace and somewhere in Antarctica or in
the TSA I've heard they're in the TSA
yeah the problem is but the problem is
like some of the stuff they've gotten
right so then they're like well
everything's right for sure right but
some of it they're dead on that's the
issue they're dead on but not in the
causes they might be dead on so for
example you could say
everybody's making money off of
narrative I can see people kind of going
well they're on kahoots though you can't
say that they're also broken clocks it
just happens
are they scared
or are they confident it's a community
so there are a lot of them can be
terrified right of like the thing that's
out there those are the those are the
ones that stay at home the ones like Sam
are great because Sam is just a comedian
who loves the idea that you know there
are there Sam has a deep deep moral
compass you know Sam uh Tripoli
he's one of the great Comics that not
enough people know about and he hasn't
been canceled is beyond me he's also
he's like a 90s comic yeah it's on the
stuff he says on stage you're not
allowed to say like what are you doing
he's always funny he's an amazing
podcaster and he's just awesome but also
I think conspiracy people the the
conspiracy is always more entertaining
than actual truth so it's way more fun
yes yes it's way more fun it's a
Hollywood movie what is the conspiracy
that's been uh that they've been correct
about
uh I mean we'll get banned for YouTube
but the pandemic yeah they were right on
that like the whole control all that
stuff there right on that JFK obviously
the big one the one you don't know if
JFK oh come on come on the government at
this point is just stupid but but I
understand that one's so easy it's it's
very easy it's very enticing to think
but I don't know that we have we still
don't have any actual measurable but why
is that like that it apparently didn't
exist yeah of course but why is that
though they still have documents that
they won't release even Trump was like
gonna release it he released some of it
was like I can't release this yeah I
don't know what do you think that is do
I think that there were people in power
who had who could have could have
probably orchestrated the assassination
of a president probably because JFK was
against Curtis Le Mansion
killing lots of people he didn't want to
go to war Germans and especially
Japanese but that one's easy though
that's on I mean yeah but I mean we're
talking about you know 60 years ago now
right but it's conspiracy of 60 years
ago it's also possible that one lone
gunman killed somebody it's also
possible that happens more often than
not alone gunmen does something like
assassinate someone or kill people so my
I always go with the sort of the least
sexy option which is yes could be I hear
you most signs point towards the could
be almost the majority of science points
especially when people start talking
about ballistics I've had my I've had
when I had my friend who has done a lot
of killing said hey dude you guys don't
know what the [__] you're talking about
when it comes to ballistics that is
exactly how a head can go sometimes take
it from a guy who's done a lot of
headshots you know so we don't know I
mean again
listen to Robert F Kennedy who it's his
uncle like people would know more than
us is what I'm saying yeah
said 60 years ago I'm saying they know
more than us though he just said his
buddies
no window did you see the window yeah
that's a shot I could take yeah of
course it is it is with that old gun 100
it's a very accurate guy M1 hey it was
an M1 yeah
okay so so that that shot as the car's
coming that shot is the moving car is as
easy to make as you can imagine it is
all those don't beg to differ and also
but but and then also
you saw it but a Navy SEAL recreate that
shot and couldn't do it that's that and
Oliver sounds a little bit crazy
guy yes and also Navy sealer did it
that's for them I don't know I don't
know I feel like it
he's a little drunk can you see yeah I
think so you know if we see how anyone
puts that much time into it it's like
sure sure there's a full documentary and
then a movie about it too yeah and what
is he saying not a heart he says he's
100 positive there's more than one
shooter and it was not just the loan
sure sure and the government was
involved you can argue that you're you
might be right for 60 years that might
be a conspiracy that I can see getting
behind I'm not saying that I have to
admit I know I've forgotten about it
it's been so long since I've talked
about this because it happened 60 years
ago yeah
literally yeah I just think that mostly
this guy goes no hundred times over and
hell no
the 10th power we uh when we were
starting out in New York City we did a
sketch about uh JFK's assassination it
was a laundry detergent commercial where
they were like this gets at tough stains
We snuck into the Smithsonian and got
JFK's blood-stained shirt and we've got
you know JFK written in white on the
shirt but we made that joke on stage and
if there was a [__] gasp from the
audience and my father who's from
Argentina got me right after the show
came up to me he's like don't you ever
do that and sketch again JFK was a great
man don't you ever do that again and I
think Kevin was getting the same thing I
was he couldn't touch it you know that
was 40 years after the fact then you
said it to me I'm gonna do that joke all
the time now it was a funny bit I mean
it was a It was a commercial we shot
like a parody but isn't that the JFK
murder it's interesting because when you
go to Dallas there's like there'll be
like Asian people like you know they
have the X they're like laying the
street taking selfies
a guy he died here I know it's been 60
years but it's
yeah like people have fun with her like
ah like with the picture like what's
that there's a line of people sure okay
and then I always gravitate towards the
one uh the guy who gives the tours
there's the real you know the the woke
tour the soy Tour
by the way there's the tour for the
Sheep right and then there's and there's
always
that she's like you want the real truth
you sure do yeah are you jump in like
his old Cadillac can go down there yeah
it's like 10 bucks oh yeah let me do it
yeah yeah because you read books on it
yeah I love it yeah I think it's
interesting how many times have you
taken a tour uh every time I'm there
it's not the fake not the one you got
the eye patch don't you want to hear
that point of view though like I've
heard it though I know all of that so
I've done the real tour my first time I
went there I was like of course yeah
well the RV Roswell was apparently like
a patriot he wasn't a communist like you
know he went over to Russia he went to
Cuba and Russia he went he went to
Russia and gave up and wanted to give up
his citizenship here and work for Russia
wasn't that the wasn't the idea I think
Oliver Stone said the idea was that he
might have been a spy for like CIA he
was doing that because he was an actual
staunch anti-communist the tangled web
that's Ruby who shot him yeah it was
crazy he's like a mafia he gets deep
yeah that's what's weird how did why did
Jack Ruby shoot him that makes no sense
then he had cancer and died and then
Jack Ruby when he was in prison they
would never let him do an interview he
was like Hey I want to tell the truth
like oh you'll figure it out and then he
died of cancer it's all weird man but
you guys keep going on your regular
tours okay but don't am I a woke sheep I
mean you're sheep yeah you're gonna take
whatever but you can find out the truth
tomorrow and it wouldn't matter because
it was 60 [__] years ago
yeah it could have been it could have
been a communist conspiracy but the
Soviet Union is a different place you
know whatever it doesn't [__] matter
the only way that was surprised like it
was an alien they were like whoa if
there's one an alien it was an alien yes
is insane but I feel like then we'd know
more [__] about it you grew up in Boston
I grew up in Connecticut Connecticut
yeah whereabouts uh New Haven West Haven
Connecticut no I'm a Giants fan really
giant New York football Giants we had
Seasons I'm New York City
oh yeah but you speak Spanish huh my
father's an immigrant now that you now
that you said you're Argentinian all I
can see is a Spanish man in front of me
yeah he's Latino he's the uh he's the
most uh successful Latino showrunner in
Hollywood
do you speak uh in Spanish
do you speak Spanish
my wife is like super Mexican tonight
okay I mean at 40. I'm not gonna pick up
Spanish isn't it mexican and italian uh
splash of attack she speaks Italian
yeah well Lemma is like so the Argentina
faction Came From Italy like five
generations ago they moved to uh
Argentina and uh Spanish for lemming do
you do your kids speak Spanish we're
giving them Spanish classes like they
take Spanish class but not like you
didn't speak in the house them growing
up no yeah no I mean my wife doesn't
speak Spanish yeah that's tough uh and
we you know when I was growing up my dad
had to learn English so we were speaking
English in our house my mom was his
English teacher that's how they met oh
that's dope is that right yeah he came
out to New York when he was 30. his dad
was that one guy in that you know
English class that got the teacher yeah
one you always think that might happen
yeah he got her right [__] her
I feel like it'd be easy to pick up your
English teacher but every guy in that
class is trying to do it oh because you
everywhere
I took uh I took a question I took a
foreign language and uh uh [__] the
teacher yeah you did yeah what uh what
do you want up in his parents story
right now I've known forever what
happened it happened what language uh
French
so you were in a class learning French I
was taking a private and you [__] your
French teacher and this older man taught
him friend
this is pretty cool man same boy that
same story man and the French guys are
not circumstances was my teacher John
jock would teach you friends you'd suck
them off right uh listen and you speak
identified as a woman yeah no you do a
little bit you can mess around with it I
mess around with it I [__] a teacher's
wife you did what one of my high school
teachers
wife hold on you yeah hold on can you
discuss it so you're this was your
teacher
he's my teacher we're a senior no so it
was uh the next year when I was a
freshman in college sixth grade oh so
next time I was a freshman College I was
back in New York and we ran into each
other
and you're like you want to get drinks
how's Mr Patterson doing how old was she
and were they swingers what was this so
she was like 30 or 32. and you're 21. I
was like 18 or 19.
if that's the other way yeah then that's
I'd say edit the story that's dangerous
but now this is cool yeah this is a good
one yeah yeah did you have that mustache
or no I did not have this mustache
I don't I don't know what happened I was
I was Charming yeah I was on my game
[__] kid and what she had long hair
then you have long hair
uh no not yet okay I bet the husband's
like I love flying the kid oh I know
that guy yeah
[__] he [__] my
wife yeah he's right now
he probably knows they're divorced they
might have been swingers or maybe yeah
well she confessed that they hadn't had
sex in two years oh okay
did you have sex in their marital bed I
did and they're marital bed but not that
first time that first time actually oh
more there's one more one okay well the
first time we had an affair we had a
seedy little Affair wow this is hot the
first the first time uh I actually
[__] her in an alley oh boy and uh in
New York City because she couldn't go to
her house and I was living at home with
my parents yeah and uh and so we did it
in an alley kind of gross wow in New
York standing up standing up Upper West
Side Upper East Side Upper West okay wow
and then I went back to college
but she and I kept in touch and then
when I came back to the city the next
time summer break we started to meet in
like poorly lit restaurants
and then I I went to their house he was
out of town okay
and I and I butt [__] her oh God now
we're really finding out some stuff
why'd you look this way and this way
nobody's just wanted to make sure he's
not around
I don't want anybody to hear this have
you ever had this happening dude that is
hilarious
I'm not ready for that maybe let's take
a little break with our friends from
Tacoma FD to the funniest guys in the
business Steve let me Kevin Heffernan
because you guys if you love money you
can make bank with our friends at
draftking Sportsbook you could win big
with money lines props parlays and more
right now new customers can score 150
dollars in bonus bets instantly for
betting just five dollars on anything
you got a UFC Fight Night coming up you
got the MLB you got the All-Star Game
there's so many ways to make Bank bro
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
right now use code
fighter that's code fighter only at
draftking Sportsbook camera problem call
one iron Gambler near a call eight seven
seven eight hope NY or text Hope NY four
six seven three six nine in West
Virginia visit dot
www.1800 gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood casinos at Charlestown Races
all games regulated by the West Virginia
Lottery please play responsibly and can
I help us available for problem gambling
call
888-789-77 or visit ccpg Dot org on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resorts
Kansas City uh 21 and over in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction see Jeff draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and say specific
responsible Gathering resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply terms at sportsbook.com
draftkings.com baseball tour if you're
still listening download DraftKings
promo code is fighter just a correction
so it's the number is
888-789-777 and terms at
sportsbook.draftkings.com
slash baseball terms don't yell at us
chin just making sure all right I had I
had this happen I had a very very close
friend very close Okay okay his longtime
girlfriend they had broken up we were
all hanging out yeah we were all hanging
out
I got for whatever reason I got the idea
that it was okay for me to have sex with
his girlfriend never okay but the way he
was talking you thought it was okay yeah
because the way he was talking he was
like you you know he was like you guys
are hitting it off and I was like green
[__] look it's one of my closest
friends to this day yeah
it's you I go home I take her home to
his place oh Jesus he's a player oh
you're a piece of [__] you can't do that
and we uh bastard yeah we we didn't have
sex I got I got
and then she goes and then she said and
I was like woohoo I didn't even mention
to him I figured he knew we were talking
what happened he wasn't staying there
he's staying with another girl Brian's a
liability huh around your girl and then
uh where are you from her and she goes
like this to me she goes literally a
month later
she goes whatever you do don't tell him
he would die
what do you mean he was nice
clothes like you and I so I was like I
was like a girl don't be selfish don't
be selfish but I mean I was like what do
you mean he would die hit my fat like
are you still friends yeah one of my
closest friends to this day it didn't
you sure do oh he doesn't know you're
sure dude I bet I know and then and then
I remember in high school same situation
yeah same situation that he had
graduated but he was my friend
and then it's a different friend yeah
and then she she made it seem like it
was fine
and then so I had sex with her okay and
then she said I'm talking to him on the
phone and I and I I was I'm like haha
and I was gonna I was like hey you know
I was gonna be like thanks and she goes
don't bring it up and I go
hey how stupid are you
going so that's the that's I like like
he's like what this is insane
I'm the victim you should call your next
tour I'll [__] your girl yeah dude
Brian's a victim these girls are toxic
yeah because you've been living with
these secrets too right literally it
hurts on the inside and I actually kind
of feel bad about it you should yeah
this is like therapy yeah so get it off
your chest man and uh yeah who else who
else listen man I was in Australia one
time you stopped by my house there's not
a shot your kids are mine because your
children are the size of me already here
they're as big as mine could they could
they beat you up his kid is his kid has
got his genetics and he's a gorilla he
had baseball today you know I mean you
guys have kiddos but he had baseball
teams like this High Elite camp and he
made the cut for baseball so he's all
nervous and I think it's good for him
but I go to drop him off at camp this
morning and all the kids because they
they're on like travel teams and like
all buddies and seven through ten but
you see all the kids like playing
together I took a picture of sent to
Brian to go I call this picture the
loneliest boy in the world because all
the kids are out there playing he's in
the Dugout just with this glove and no
one's talking to him
I was like oh no but I went through that
I'm like yeah I can't be like hey tiger
meat whatever you know so I just had to
leave him I was like oh no he's so cute
how lonely was that picture but his neck
is this thick
like there's a special bench and if
you're feeling lonely you go sit in the
bench and then all the kids know that
you want them to come talk to you
where's that at some school some some
friend of mine said that has three kids
that's in L.A yeah because it's like
it's that same thing the kid's sitting
there like lonely and now if the kids
sit on that bench the other kids know
they should go talk to him to be nice to
him man we hope those other kids know
that that's like the but not really
to go sit on that bench either well what
do you know is there a cool bench I
might sit on the gold maybe maybe it's
the oldest guy who doesn't want people
to come talk to him yeah yeah yeah but
as a parent like I remember my parents
dropped me off when I was in sixth grade
at the University of Colorado Football
Camp and you're staying in the dorm for
two weeks yeah I don't have any friends
it's just you have to learn those you
know I used to learn those kind of
hardships you know yeah it's
heartbreaking it's a bad I did that I
went to make friends buddy I went to a
soccer camp when I was 11 in Connecticut
and uh I told all the kids that I was a
street fighter from New York City hell
yeah
and they believed me they [__]
believed me who else wants something and
then and then the older kids like the 14
year old kids came down to our floor to
[__] Rumble and I was in in my
[__] dorm room and I heard one of
them go like hey you watch out we got a
guy here he's a street fighter from New
York City
[Laughter]
I had a guy uh Nick my buddy said it was
my feature said that they're they're a
guy asked him a guy goes hey uh how
would um he's talking about some comic
maybe preacher Lawson who's an awesome
guy I love preacher but he was like uh
he should fight Brennan they should do a
fight and I was like
don't you can't you can't get that
Twisted now don't preacher lessons
athletic converter oh cause preacher
wants to fight right yeah
but I was like and I love Nick who is a
wrestler yeah the guy and goes that
would be a very bad idea for everybody
involved there's no upside for me
preacher's a great guy yeah but do you
have a thing like like so I was saying
Stipe came and did that episode of
Tacoma FD and like he he brought his you
know he was getting ready for that
Nagano fight and so his trainers were
with him second fight yeah the second
fight and so he was working out while we
were while we were shooting but I was
like for Stipe and his trainer I was
like this must be [__] annoying
because everybody who has done any sort
of mixed martial arts or wrestling is
coming up to them
yeah but how was he on set he's a good
dude [__] great he's like such a good
person such a good guy yeah the biggest
head not not I'm saying physically the
biggest head I've ever seen huge his
head is true it was funny because we we
like the plot of the episode is he comes
and does like our firefighters have a
podcast and he does their podcast but
they've been trashing him and he just
stops by because he's doing a fight in
Tacoma and he's looking at all the
firefighter houses and so he he does
their podcasts but then he finds out
that they were trashing him oh that's
funny and so he comes back and [__]
kicks the [__] out uh and so our our A.D
was like do you want to get like uh some
stunt uh doubles in here because like
sometimes these like real Fighters get
excited and they can hurt people and I
was like no it's gonna be fine it's
gonna be like you know like he's just
slapping them yeah and so yeah
he's supposed to smack the guy Gabe who
plays like Crystal six foot four guy
he takes the first swing and you know
Gabe is supposed to go down and all of a
sudden uh Stipe looks in we're because
we're like shooting from behind a door
and he and he's like holy [__] I hit him
I hit him for real and and we all start
laughing we think it's a little bit
they're doing and he's like no I I
seriously I hit your [__] guy and now
we see all these like crew members going
over yeah his fingertip clipped uh our
guy's nose
and that knocked him that [__]
knocked him yeah to the ground but it
was like a like a holy [__] he [__]
really hit him and like steep a felt
terrible everybody felt terrible was
that what season was that because were
you guys on season five no four that was
three are you still like everything else
that on True TV has been canceled except
for Tacoma I think True TV has been
canceled there's nothing it's just good
auditioned for the the first season yeah
yeah just for the first season that's
when I realized like Hollywood like I
was like I'm a big guy I'll stick out
and I go because they're all like big
firefighters the role I'm supposed to
read for and I sit down I'm like oh
everybody looks like me but better I was
like I was like what is happening right
now everybody
oh no they're stained with like soot
like I don't know if they could excited
to meet you I mean yeah I don't know
they'd look like it yeah that was a guy
the guy who got the part like you guys
were in the waiting room together yeah
and then first of all when he walked in
we were like ah look at his biceps oh I
was rock hard when he sat down I was
like oh I'm not getting this at least I
got to see what was this a role for a
fighter for not firefighter firefighter
yeah but it was like the big the big
dumb firefighter he's like I he's big
and [__] jacked and everything yeah
and this guy came up with a mustache and
he's a beautiful oh he's a beautiful man
and his biceps we were like holy what's
his name what's his name is Gabe Hogan
Gabe Hogan right when I saw it please by
the way that's a great name Gabe Hogan
Gabriel Hogan yeah there you go that's a
big handsome son of a [__] yeah there
you go oh well come on you're not gonna
get yeah he's a firefighter I mean what
are we doing I mean what are you doing
you're not getting that part I called my
agent I'm like you ever seen Gabe Hogan
you piece of [__] you send me on this
goddamn audition click click on that
middle one go back up a little bit there
that one right below right below this
one yeah he's also like look at he's a
[__] [__] too
[Laughter]
he's like he's like uh he he played uh
it's a big kid yeah he's done like he he
started he's Canadian he should always
have a mustache by the way it's a good
look yeah it's a good look on the
mustache yeah never shave the mustache
yeah
um but he's the one that that steep a
hit and he just went down like a [__]
I Batman nothing
um
yeah there he is and I took home a hat
yeah but but here's here's the thing it
did a good job you did a good job it's
really hard to act he really did it's
really hard to sort it like yeah not
like like yeah like Woody Harrelson did
it in cheers like a dumb guy but yeah
because he acted like he was always
watching a Disney movie right yeah yeah
yeah and it's a really [__] I think
it's it like that part was where we
learned that we're like holy [__] like
nobody it is nailing this and this guy
came in I heard my feelings so you guys
said don't act them just play yourself
but just you know over you're overacting
just do what you do in normal life
it says really dumb guy in her like we
know just play yourself here that's
exactly but you know that's like that's
like um I played a guy I got the part
but then we didn't shoot it but I
remember I had a great note from an
acting teacher because I was there was a
huge Rock in the in the way and you know
they were like the idea is how do we get
it out of the way and the line is we can
burn it
let's burn it he's so dumb right now and
so so yeah so so the dumb way to do it
at first I was doing I was like well
let's just burn it you know right and he
was like no man you're smarter than
everybody in the room yeah so I was like
guys
let's burn it out of the way
right and I think I was well but it's
made of rock and I'm like and I have
matches
you know and then I got the part because
I but I wouldn't have but that's how
smart dumb people are like you're a
[__] idiot yeah they're positive yeah
well I have the evidence that there are
UFOs because it's in on the internet
that's basically my career yeah yeah
yeah it's confidence yeah even if you're
dead wrong yeah that's always how it is
just dumb as [__] people and we all have
some of that in US
I used to have arguments with my father
and I would and I'd be [__] dead and
my father was a just a nightmare with
that he'd go wow did you see the part
where you sped up do you see how your
words sped up that's the part where you
just made that stuff up
sometimes when you argument I wish there
was just a white flag really enough all
right I don't know what the [__] I'm
talking about just let me out of here
especially if you get an argument with a
debater or my brother
it's been two hours dude here's the
[__] Flag your brother has to do
something else piece of information and
will not Retreat doesn't raise his voice
but he's right here he's holding his
Grouch it's like playing tennis against
a guy who's always going to hit it back
he's right here with all the information
don't argue don't get an argument well
this Porsche is better what this team is
better this guy's better this guy's a
better shooter and he'll don't do that
unless you you'll see the White Flag
like all right dumbass why does he do
that though is it was it something in
his childhood that makes him uh my dad
likes our you too I liked argues I think
it's just that family Dynamic but he
doesn't realize when he wins the one
time I saw him almost come to blows was
talking about it's easy to be a parent
he doesn't have kids I was gonna fight
him yeah having a mom it's not a job
Casino we just got on the show and he
came and they're both really my former
manager yeah and he I just had my first
son and we're like going through it man
kid's not sleeping and I'm exhausted we
got off stage we're like eating after
the show and I know he's like I mean
being a mom's not a job it's not a job
what he's like it's [__] go do you
feed the kids [__] I'm like you don't
know what you're talking about then he
wouldn't get off of it I mean I'm in his
face like this because you're a [__]
idiot I'm like dude we gotta stop it it
was like the brother older younger older
older and he's not backing down and it
doesn't matter Brandon's a heavy weight
in UFC it doesn't matter he would have
fought him right then right there it
wouldn't have mattered it was going to
be did you guys fight physically no no
no no younger yes yeah awfully yeah
horrible did he get the best of you oh
my records like one in two thousand but
the one was good yeah yeah yeah I mean
at some point you must have come to the
place where you could get the gym by the
time I did we were best friends so
there's no need to beat him up but I
wish had those skills when I was younger
but he but he made you the man you are
today yeah oh wow okay yeah yeah I used
to fight with my sister my older sister
and you're one in two thousand yeah
older sisters are there but they're
always strong she was a ballerina she
was a [__] ballerina and she would
she would do she had two moves she'd
call me over and either punch me in the
nose or she'd uh give me a flying kick
like in the chest really Anthony pastel
yeah but finally I joined the wrestling
team and one time I kicked her ass and
smothered her with a pillow and when I
brought it up she was crying like hey
dude that's a girl what the [__] are you
doing no he wasn't home my mom my mom
was there though yeah my sister my
daughter beats the [__] out of her like
she'll just kick my my son my son like I
try to teach him stuff and he's just not
he's just more of a just a puppet he's
just like a magician your daughter's a
minus 1700 again my daughter is she's a
full-grown woman yeah and but she's
still 15 and my son just he keeps doing
this because he wants the pain and
finally she just goes gouge with one of
her big legs she's got my she's got her
mom's legs just long Viking legs goes
right in his chest
it can't breathe it's just [__] what
how old is he though he's younger he's
11. he's going to be 12. so there'll be
a time though yeah he hasn't hit I don't
know dude I don't know if there's a time
if you've seen his kids like he's gone
he's a Savage man does she have a back
as muscular as yours nobody does foreign
it's a pull-up regime do we have do you
guys have a minute okay so what you take
it I've never done a pull-up in my life
not even that's crazy because the first
thing I've never done look at you Kevin
is right I know I know number once
you're not you're never a one you're not
a big exercise guy
I can't I do exercise but I don't I
can't do a pull-up do exercise-wise what
am I doing exercise don't take the space
you know when you're interviewing and
you're a cop and somebody goes where did
I put the where did I where was I where
was I on that day do I exercise do I I
mean he didn't hear the question well
but then also gets dicey because Brian
you know he likes exercise I think he
knows exercising so it gets dicey too
he's gonna ask you that to give his
recommendations sure and then the
viewership of the podcast oh I'll give
it I'll give a record I'll give you
supplement ideas if you're a
professional exerciser I'll give you a
record no I'll tell you this at that
moment when you're asking that question
I think Kevin could read this too like
uh your eyes had the most Delight in
them so far of this session
this was the best my neighbor I'm a dick
my neighbor said we should play tennis
sometime I'm such a piece of [__] and I
go uh I go I go like this I go yeah but
are you good
I mean yeah I hit the ball I go
I go let me see your stroke and he goes
he goes
these are two grown men
I go like this I go you don't follow
through I can't play with you
and I was 90 serious are your kids in
sports yeah big time
yeah my daughter plays uh she plays you
know on the Collegiate level now oh damn
she plays lacrosse and um cross country
love looking my wife is I mean you know
I'm an athletic guy don't get me wrong
Carolyn I'm not saying anybody uh I
understand I've never heard a pull
before that's one thing I've never done
and I never will okay I can't I can't
even in high school like Middle School
never I was the kid who couldn't climb
the rope and gym classy to climb the
Rope never climb the Rope not everybody
has lots like me that's true and you
know and I brought up your background
every time I've seen you do stand-up
comedy usually the whole routine is
about your back and the shinuous
I'm a one note guy it works though yeah
I think you know maybe and squats
sometimes squats squats you gotta hit
did your kids want to get into Hollywood
at all they have we put them in Tacoma a
little bit
um they've gone through stretches where
they have we put them in uh I put them
in Super Trooper the last Super Troopers
movie uh but it's kind of like
we have this kind of family that makes
these shows and these movies and they
know everybody and like they know the
crew and the sound guy's been with us
for 25 years and comes to my house for
barbecues so it's like you know that's
so cool when they do it it's like it's
like family yeah it's not like an
uncomfortable like going to a set or
auditioning or whatever so uh they don't
have any uh aspirations to do it you
know but Super Troopers is truly a cult
classic yeah hey tell me if this is
right or wrong this is the the urban
legend go around online the Super
Troopers just DVD sales was over 100
million dollars oh yeah yeah definitely
yeah 100 million dollars Brian so you
guys got some cash no it's funny because
we didn't get the deal the deal that we
made we all we wanted was to have a
movie in one theater like back then we
were you know we made that movie
independently for a million bucks Tina
Meyer is a friend of mine oh really I
love her yeah
who's that
it's my shoes and Super Troopers Dina or
Tina Dina what what uh well let me just
a partnership let me make sure the
podcast came to Screech and Hope
I'm sorry what partition
no no she's Starships
I'm sorry stupid I'm sorry [__]
stupid guy you [__] [__] I love
you guys are talking about Super
Troopers and girls Morgan Freeman's a
friend of mine do you still think it's a
call Classic do you think it's still
things oh cause you thought there was
aliens you know you piece of [__] that's
the one I sat next to a guy on a plane
and he asked me about my career and I
was talking about Super Troopers and
he's like I love that [__] movie and
you're awesome and I was like thank you
very much he's asking questions about
the film business we're talking 30
[__] minutes on the plane and at the
end he's like and what was the budget I
was like a million in quarters like a
million a quarter what about all the
bugs
and I was like you're thinking of
Starship Troopers he's like yeah yeah
yeah what uh movie are you talking about
Super Troopers he's like oh I've never
heard of that movie meanwhile he said he
loved me yeah
Allen yeah it's a movie where I play
cops I thought Mike Weaver's in it
you're friends with Mike
Weaver's the best
I'm flabbergasted yeah I'm so sorry guys
Ryan's like I love that movie and as
you're telling story he goes Tom Hanks
is a friend
we have a lot of deep fakes in here yeah
that's a good recovery it's also kind of
like maybe Dina is the one that's been
telling you the [__] story
[__] she maybe she is you guys made that
movie in hopes to be at one theater we
want to be in one theater and they put
us on I think like 1200 screens but the
deal we made at the time was like
Preposterous like they the the claim by
the studio was that the amount of money
they were going to spend like they
weren't going to break even
but also the guy who put the money up I
mean we you know we sold our first born
child you know there's a guy who put up
a million bucks
you know he did very well but like uh it
was also in that moment it doesn't exist
anymore but when DVD was King you know
it was like you know they could make him
for five cents and they sell them for 20
bucks it's harder than 100 million money
right like off film because you guys are
in that we're writing a film shooting a
film selling a film it's very hard to
make money isn't it well yeah it depends
on who distributes it you can't
it's hard to find how much money they
spend you know yeah yeah which is why
you take the fees up front yeah because
they're gonna [__] you they're gonna 100
yeah yeah that idea if I'm gonna get
back end points okay uh once the movie
starts returns a profit okay but then
you you guys came up where like you guys
I know New York and Connecticut but you
guys met where like how did this dynamic
duo come together we went to college
together went to Colgate University in
Upstate New York so all of us there's
like schools good toothpaste very good
school yeah good school he hated him he
hated me what did you study
political science
you that was fine arts as a painter You
Were A Painter painter yeah he this guy
gets more [__] Spanish he really does
yeah or a beret did you when did you do
this [__] now did you yeah no [__]
you're [__] girls man yeah
how long was the gay phase though did
you guys a lot of guys or or you know
listen you say that but like the whole
thing was my friend sperber was like
dude let's be Art majors
and he was like I've been to the art
studio there are so many hot chicks over
there he's like and they drink wine
he's like let's go drink wine and paint
things and hang out with these chicks I
was like I'm so [__] in yeah that's
exactly what did your dad said you had
to go but do you like money yeah my
father would have been like come over
here what did you say to me you think I
paid for you to go culture you could
paint
yeah and here's the thing so my father
was a chemical engineer in Argentina oh
wow and at age 30 he was like there must
be a better he said it in Spanish but
there must be a better life in America
and so he left Argentina at age 30. and
came to America he didn't speak any
English he couldn't get a job because
they were like [__] his English
teacher first of all you you have to you
have to learn English and also you have
to have an American degree in chemical
engineering so now he had to go back to
chemical engineering school so he's
already done this so another four years
in chemical engineering and he's
learning English at the same time
he couldn't get a job so he was selling
hot dogs in Times Square and he was a
dishwasher at a restaurant God dang uh
he [__] his uh English teacher yes
anyway yeah so my mom then went on to be
a a Spanish teacher well he did and it's
clear that he [__] her on the first
night because uh because he said then he
was like there the first day was dinner
the second date was breakfast together
well you know it's a it's a custom in
Argentina when you fall in love with a
woman you follow her home to make sure
she gets home safely that's assault bro
that's [__] stalking yeah yeah
America's assault yeah and he was like
no no this is a flirtation you you let
her know you are following her home I'm
like that's [__] worse that's sick
I'm gonna be right behind you yeah I'm
here
he got his chemical engineering degree
in America after learning English to
study that [__] then he got like a
Masters in Business Administration did
all that [__] Rose to Beast you know
Rose to a nice position but my mom
became a teacher at a very elite private
school in New York City and so to send
me there they had to spend a [__] ton of
money that they didn't have so my dad
was in debt every year to send my sister
and me to that school
and then Senior Year I dropped out of
college wow and he because of
entertainment uh no he's a [__]
because I drunkenly severed my
attorney's tendon the day before classes
started and I couldn't get to I couldn't
make it to class for the first couple of
weeks and so I was just behind at
Thanksgiving I stayed home damn and so
like that party how did you separate
your attend uh like a fake karate fight
and like [__] kicked through a like a
glass door oh no [__] yes ever 44. so
then where does the the theater and like
the The Improv come together for you
guys
so that was our June that was my junior
his senior year my senior year uh jade
Chinese are one of the other guys
he said [__] uh he using Starship
Troopers yeah the bugs he was in the
Super he was in uh spaceship Troopers
but yeah he used to direct a lot of the
schools yeah yeah right Goldberg's yeah
yeah yeah yep and um uh he uh he kind of
he had been in Chicago and he wanted to
start a comedy group at College at
Colgate there's nothing like it there so
he started he kind of gathered a bunch
of people together and we did like an
improv show sketch show and it was you
know
the Five Guys who were left were part of
that original group so the Five Guys who
were still broken lizard or whatever so
um so we did shows at Colgate and um and
we kind of did comedy shows and
uh stand up shows and [__] like that and
you know and then we moved to New York
how's Jay doing talk good yeah yeah no
he's doing well he's interacting he's
directing he's doing he's doing a bunch
of stand-up now he's trying to shoot a
special next week he did yeah he's gonna
shoot it in Chicago no [__] yeah so he's
been he's been traveling around stand up
funny guy yeah he's good
he's directing a lot of TV and and um
and then you know we made another movie
we had a movie that came out in April
called quasi it's on Hulu uh and so we
were doing that for a while and um
but you know Adina Myers is in that room
regularly now are you uh are you are you
doing any um a stand-up you guys are
both doing stand-up we haven't done in a
while I think since Tacoma started we
just haven't had time yeah it's been
five years because
there's there's the new movie quasi and
we realized that like uh it's great it's
medieval it's about it's about the
Hunchback that looks like real Hunchback
[__] would that cost you yeah
it was uh we did it on the cheap we did
it uh what it cost us I don't know it
was under 15 million bucks damn and uh
we shot it up in um Santa Clarita
and we built a French a French medieval
village up there and we shot a
hunchback
so great up there let me let me Place
The Hunchback who directed it I did he
did
and then in Tacoma why Tacoma why Tacoma
fire because that was the that we were
trying to we look we we reverse
engineered it Super Troopers 2 was
coming out and we were like all right we
got to get on TV because we I think
we've done like 14 we'd sold like 14 TV
shows and never one reason they wouldn't
make it it would shoot a pilot it
wouldn't make it or you know and so we
were like people like us with our
mustaches what other jobs we've got
mustaches and we're like firefighters
all right so what's the hook and we're
like well Super Troopers was
highway patrolman on the most deserted
stretch of highway in the country what's
the equivalent of that for a firefighter
we're like the rainiest city in the
country have nothing to [__] do and
so there and we were in Tacoma at the
time we're doing the Tacoma Comedy Club
great great great club
we were there for the weekend it was
like you know overcast and whatever like
right here man what the firefighters do
here it's raining all the [__] time
right you know so we we so whatever so
then we did we they announced the show
we were doing shows in Seattle and uh
and uh the manager of the club came back
and he's like hey there's a bunch of
Tacoma firefighters here uh they want to
talk to you they're like holy [__] and
so we went out after the show and talked
to him and they were pissed because the
word had got around in the Press we were
you know the it was the rainiest city
and they're like we just want you to
know we fight a lot of fires you know
and like you know we were kind of scared
or whatever and like they were kind of
you know get Madness and then after the
whole conversation the guy like pulls
out a business card and he goes I also
do technical Consulting
oh thanks buddy that we became friends
with those guys like we actually
premiered Tacoma FD at a charity event
firefighters yeah and that guy was there
do you have a real loyal cult following
yeah I mean it's crazy because like
there's what like three or four million
firefighters in the country in in the
country or whatever and you know they
all
all the firefighter shows on TV are
those ones where it's like you know
there's a lot of crying and it's you
know uh dramatic and soot they just yeah
they want to see the show where they're
[__] around in the station because
that's what they're doing that's what
they do yeah yeah so I think our Chicago
Fire like ours was when the first one
that you know some that did that and you
know I have a family that are
firefighters and my cousin is our
technical consultant he he hangs on the
set and he gives us stories and makes
sure we look right and and you know
people say that it's very accurate to
the firefighter world because they're
just having all the actors
they don't like me everybody's just like
just they're so hot they're really good
looking oh she's intense tomboys but hot
as [__]
gosh I do a lot of wrist curls their
forearms are no joke
yeah and then you got me I've never had
a pull-up guys well I'd rather have a
fireman like you look at the way they're
standing oh
yeah
baby oil can we get one
get more to take themselves too
seriously yeah the black guy looks so
uncomfortable well that's it and look at
the loser [__] naked yeah look at the
loser lady doctor in the back left there
she looks like she wandered she would
look she wanted on but that's why we do
those things as a like we do shots like
that as a joke
yeah Chicago Fire get the Tacoma FD
season three poster uh up there please
watch this look at this [__] [__]
right here season two the season two oh
that's season two shoot it where
Woodland Hills oh really around here
right on the burial and Irwin oh [__]
yeah we we built this uh I'm always over
there there you go yeah we we found this
like empty office complex yeah that one
that built the station inside of it so
dumb look at that [__] sweet poster
even she has a mustache in the back it's
really funny it's so funny that's really
that's to show you it's a comedy because
otherwise you would think we were just
as [__] hot as yeah yeah I like
Chicago yeah fire department yeah yeah
so you got to put a mustache on that's
hilarious let's take a little break
because it's time for some nuts in your
mouth Time For Less carbs it's time for
nuts that are 33 less less in carbs I'm
a vegan paleo Keto we're talking about
the best profile you can get I'm talking
about nuts you're talking about this
they're like avocados on steroids bro
dip macadamias chocolate macadamia
macadamia nuts yeah they've got they've
got rare omega-7 fatty acids that that
can that has been LED that can support
natural collagen production glucose
metabolism so if you've got problems
with you know your your blood sugar and
it reduces inflammation and it's also
been linked to longevity and fat loss
which is why world record epigenetic Age
reducer Brian Johnson includes
macadamias in his daily diet all the
smart kids are doing it and macadamas
used to be just for the rich not anymore
because House of macadamias is changing
all this they work with not over 90
Farmers to bring you the cheapest
macadamias possible all right and they
have a range of products from hand
sorted nuts with Savory all natural
flavors even dipped in sugar-free
chocolate my personal favorites creamy
chocolate flavor here cold pressed extra
virgin Macadamia Oil which I use always
when I cook my steaks it's unbelievable
it's got a buttery flavor it's got a
high smoke point all right so my
favorite's a little treat is the 45
Macadamia snack bars all right no added
sugar or artificial ingredients dude
they have variety of flavors like
blueberry coconut White Plain chocolate
regular chocolate you know what I'm
gonna do if you want to try out that
variety
coconut white chocolate plain chocolate
how about you get a free box of 45 Mac
demon snack bars one of each flavor then
pick your favor then order the whole box
of them when you visit
houseomeacademias.com tfak plus 20 off
your entire order with the code tfak get
you some macadamia nuts in your mouth
houseamact damius.com tfak
um but I don't I mean to go back and
think firefighters they love it they
yeah they reach now they just give us
their stories you know what I mean and
we'll you know there's a each one of
them's got like a hundred great stories
you know and you just yeah that's how
you write it you just come up with like
an idea and then yeah yeah that was a
50th birthday party for somebody and uh
we were partying late night and our
friend was standing up drinking a beer
and he just [__] collapsed in this
hotel room and I was like oh I got down
there I was like I revived him I did
some of my firefighter training I was
like hey uh what's your name he said his
name I was like do you know who I am he
said my name I said you know what year
it is do you know where you are and he's
like yeah yeah
I was like I think you should stay down
there he's like I'm fine he stood up was
up for another minute and then [__]
collapsed again and this time he almost
hit his head like on an end table and I
was like to the other people in the room
I'm like I'm calling the fire I'm
calling 9-1-1 and people like I don't
think you should you know he's been
doing coke and I was like definitely
call the fire I'm like I'm calling them
like he's [__] he's he's green
whatever color he was so they came they
like revived him they did the whole
[__] [__] put him through tests and
everything and meanwhile while that's
going on
a female firefighter Whispers in my ear
she's like
Eddie panizzi
he was like I am
can I get a picture with you after this
is pretty awesome did you hear that the
bunch of uh cops it was at a convention
and they there they had rented this
Suite this hotel room suite and they're
like literally 30 or 40 of them and
they're all in this they're all kind of
sitting around I think they're waiting
to watch a game or something they're all
sitting around some on the bed some on
the chairs they're drinking they're
talking it's just like a great kind of
love us a dude comes in with a gun and
tries to rob them what you just didn't
know you just didn't know their cops
because but all your watches and all the
cops are like
and they just jump on them at the same
time they basically all jumped on them
Wrestled a gun from them and stuff like
that and then when they they kind of got
the gun away from him he was dead holy
[__] he had a heart attack holy [__] oh
he's doing the cops now what's that no
he just died trying to rob them and they
got the gun away and he just ended up
dying in a hotel somewhere
yeah that uh I mean when that happens
that kind of [__] we have a lot of cop
stories just because of Super Troopers
we were doing not Starship Troopers you
must get some crazy stories we were
doing a show in Missouri a weekend in
Missouri and on Thursday night after
that show we were like Thursday's when
we typically don't party at all because
you got to wake up for something you do
that Friday morning radio and all that
[__] yeah but we pulled into the hotel
on Thursday anyway to check in and
they're probably like 50 Missouri State
uh cop cars in the parking lot and they
were having their convention there oh
yeah and so you know whatever we did our
show we got back on Thursday night I was
in his hotel room we were going over the
game plan for the morning stone cold
sober
I go and I get in the elevator we say
good night we say good night I get in
the elevator with all this all these
[__] cops and then one of them goes
you boys like Mexico which is one of my
lines from Super Troopers and I was like
the one with bugged yeah yeah
you got me and they're like you're
[__] coming partying with us
and it was that it was them in a hotel
room just sitting around passing bottles
of whiskey great good times great you
know 30 minutes later we're driving a
7-Eleven in a squad car to get
cigarettes you know the whole [__]
thing these guys [__] me up
but they all use the the key uh phrases
you you use in Super Troopers my
father-in-law is a highway patrol
officer they all use the yeah [__]
with each other yeah oh yeah it's like
all of them follow it I'm sure huge
Falls over speeding but you guys
probably Drive the speed limit but if
you if you no we don't yes you take the
road the way I do if you take it yeah
you know what I'm saying yeah I know
exactly yeah yeah and when I take the
road somebody get pulled over and they
go
[__]
[Laughter]
I did get pulled over doing 120 and the
guy leaned in he's like Mister do you
have any idea how Super Troopers
110 miles an hour and the uh it's
probably a lot right I wasn't doing 110
you're probably going 88. I was I was
going very fast though and it was uh I
get pulled over in a speech wrap and the
guy from from World's Dumbest you know
they all watched that too he just looks
good and he goes like that he goes he
goes
what's gonna happen next season and I go
I'm not telling her [__] yeah that was
it the last time I pulled over was right
here because you know there's the
sheriff's uh you know
I got pulled over uh driving to uh
there's oh there's there's a
construction thing so I was driving to
the Tacoma set I had a firefighter coat
on yeah and the guy pulled me over and
it was like six o'clock in the morning
because I rolled through the stop sign
and uh and there he was and he was like
you know
are you a firefighter and I was like No
I
this one you sound like you know [__]
like no I shoot a firefighter show uh so
I was like oh you're an actor I said
yeah because we recognize you
oh and then he let me he just let me go
you have a good time you know yeah and
uh but it was right this is the last
time right here right on if you're an
actor you're gonna get [__] if you're
a comic if you're if you if you make
people laugh a lot of times yeah yeah
it's like
you get off but if you make a movie
about cops then you're set we've been uh
you know so many times have been let out
of tickets you know oh yeah you gotta
you got pulled over for speeding
to go throw out a pitch at the uh yeah
we were throwing out first pitch of the
Padres game I'd be nervous about that
how'd you do
um that time I actually saw the picture
recently I did pretty well
but I I have bounced it a couple times
yeah I have bounced it like I I went
when I was a Kevin based gym I was
practicing throwing it's actually a lot
farther than it's a lot farther and also
like the you know it's like a weird like
you had that one moment the adrenaline
and you kind of [__] it up on there have
you ever done that I haven't I'd love to
though yeah I'd love to Theo did it with
the Arizona Diamondbacks and people
forget how athletic Theo is
he did I told him if you want to go
viral like he should have done like the
50 Cent like I I think 50 Cent did that
on purpose you do yeah there's no way no
way how do you not throw a ball what
about well his throwing motion was
awesome everything was a night like
cheddar Sagar just did it at the Cubs
this last a couple months ago he
practiced because he's a huge Cubs fan
he can finally get the chance it was for
uh quasi the movie quasi practice
practice and then
just embarrassed me like it didn't even
get halfway to the ma today let me see
50 cents because that was so crazy you
know Jeff died he he his goal I think
it's the only reason to stand up his
goal is to pitch at every Major League
Stadium I think he's done okay 30 of
them wow and he's throwing it in there
man well yeah
just so you know there's a chance he
never threw no way that's that's there's
a chance he'll grow up in New York
that's not embarrassing no it is though
it's he probably never threw a ball dude
Connor threw it through the ball well
but then when he threw for the for the
Dallas Cowboys the football yeah oh
you're so oh dude that was now Ireland
came out yeah so it was like what about
your basketball oh no what about your
boy the basketball but that's what that
was 50 Cent that was bad yeah you know
grew up in the New York over there I
mean the which one yeah no [__] ball
dude yeah you're from the [__] Bronx
you live next to the Yankees yeah dude
what about who's that basketball player
who threw the ball terribly the the best
the number one draft pick in the NBA
right now oh Victorious
he's the one who beat up Britney Spears
there's a pitch oh you know his security
guard slap Britney Spears yeah have you
seen that yeah the top one yeah yeah the
top one too did you see this well now
real quick he's 7-4 yeah he looks like I
think he's seven five what country is he
from though he's from France so it's
like not like he grew up playing
baseball
the first time he's seen a ball
oh that's terrible isn't bad that wasn't
terrible no no that's terrible it might
be good for you but that's terrible
gotta let it roll off your finger I know
he did your back prevention he's got no
back muscles that's the problems you
ever see Bush when he was President W
bush throw the ball hello after 9 11.
not too bad though no no he threw some
heat too yeah well he played he played
college baseball
I don't think he did baseball
cheerleaded him he played for Yale this
was the first uh game after 9 11. now
remember his family owns the Texas
Rangers yeah it's true
there you go from the mound too well how
about him throw that let me know how it
goes for you exactly that's a good throw
right there
not bad though I wonder if there's any
of our pitches anywhere
uh Sanders uh the one that he threw in
the dirt is up there the Cubs you guys
bat rolled it in that makes me sad did
he go up and then roll I think the last
one I did was uh at the Charlotte
Knights yeah and you were talking about
he was talking a big game about that
Minor League Baseball he's like you're
gonna [__] bounce this you're putting
this in the drama c-h-a-n-d-r-a
yep now d-r-a-o-c-k
uh s-e-k
s-e-k-h-a-r-h-r it took me a long time
to figure out
they don't even have it in there yeah
it's his name is worth it same one worth
it that's how bad it was his middle name
is jumbo lingam which means big [__]
she's that's your middle name right
on the street Brian jumbling in the
exact circles and the uh
sure I don't think you're gonna find
that one you won't find that one you
might find it oh there it is there it is
on Tick Tock Wrigley Field though that's
a big deal his jersey is a nightmare
Wrigley that's his uh that's his name
from Starship Troopers that was his name
in the movie from Starship Troopers
from Starship I remember
nobody's in the snap nobody's there
oh
bounce at all and it's off to the side
the crowd's not feeling it it's just
remember he like he had one of our
buddies bring a a baseball mitt and a
baseball to the the night before we did
a screening so he could throw uh at the
yeah you got the screening so you
practice Yeah you got to practice and he
did a little bit and it's just the
Mounds up too yeah because like the
Dodgers you can elect to go from the
mound or closer yeah you see the
Kardashians Kevin Hart they'll do it
closely you got to get on the mountain
we did I'm getting on the [__] we did
the doctor we did the mound you did the
mound yeah you got it yeah but people
don't realize the amount it's higher so
it's kind of thrown down what I was
doing schools I was working with a lot
of kid actors I I cannot I was playing a
coach right so I cannot tell you how
many kids couldn't throw a ball 14 year
old sure Hollywood actress when I'm
telling you I'm telling you they grew up
acting like playing with it they
couldn't throw up a baseball or a
football it was just I'm unimaginable
it's not what they do though never die
they're busy you're supposed to teach
them you're a coach yeah and these kids
are supposed to wear your coach
reflection mom the mom the dad was
around
I remember there's a famous
actress and her she son didn't have a
father and I spent some time with him
and I was so apparent to me this young
boy who was probably 11
um I don't know had never just been
around a guy never been a [__] around a
guy who could teach him how to do [__]
let's teach him how to like do like guy
stuff we were [__] around with a ball
football fix his balls that kind of
thing fix your balls yeah no punch yeah
no spiral yeah [__] a teacher eat a
slice of pizza boom yeah you know what
I'm saying in the butt yeah
do it in the butt yeah but don't look
around that way
you need a father for you to teach you
like you know just make sure that's true
you know what you need a father figure
for it whatever I do is that my my
nephew my two nephews torture my younger
nephew if they're young they're younger
brother but you need brothers or men
around to [__] with you a little bit
Yeah tease you yeah you're not so
sensitive yeah teach you about the House
of Pain yeah the house of pain in this
world guys test each other they [__]
with each other it's like come on man
this is we're just bonding here we're
just [__] yeah it's not serious
all right uh first one is from this
Northwestern coach so this is nuts okay
so let me be honest here so this code
it's hazing so Patrick Fitzgerald he was
a All-American linebacker at
Northwestern University he would when I
that I was telling you when I went to
University of Colorado Football Camp
yeah he was my coach and he was awesome
oh [__] he was awesome to me he made
he's like oh you never make it your feet
are too big you know obviously I made it
so suck on that yeah so that's what I've
I've never liked the guy I've never
liked that but he's a good coach so this
article comes out you knew him yes and
he's very mean to me as a kid really
yeah super mean he said my feet were too
big I'll never make it so that's cool so
you loved seeing this story I don't with
this but what I what things go on so as
Northwestern players allege hazy
includes barbaric course sexual acts
yeah yeah yeah and you go down when you
read about it I grew up in locker rooms
yeah man sure when you read this you're
like oh it's just a bunch of gay dudes
on Northwest that's all this is
him so it said the current player
claimed Coach Pat Fitzgerald who's spend
without pay for two weeks it's gonna be
way longer than that after this oh it
might have been aware he was not hazing
no no no but he wasn't one of the guys
freshman messed up they have a sign
where they they like circle around their
head he would throw that sign when the
kid messed up when the older players
know like go for him that's opposed
supposedly with these kids I see I see
so they call it running so I'm involved
being restrained by a group by eight to
ten upperclassmen dressed in Mass who
would then dry hump the victim in a dark
locker room in shocking experience
that's fresh to see your fellow freshmen
teammates get ran keep going but then it
gets really homophobic keep going down
uh everyone just looking at you telling
me like bro Fitz knows about this
everyone joins him because he's the
coach
there's a there's a part there keep
going
and is it is it a fact that the coach
knew that this stuff naked and perform
and bear bear crawling so they'd run
around uh play they call it the car wash
on which some players would stand naked
at the entrance of the showers and spin
around forcing anyone to enter to rub up
against them it's like I grew up in
locker room man that stuff I'm in a
million locker rooms nobody ever was
naked in the shower rubbing up again
yeah I think just some of the
Northwestern players are scared to come
out of the closet yeah it's really weird
isn't that weird you want to put my dick
all over you dude you better take this
is hazy I've heard plenty of those
stories though hold your arms above your
head and start clapping because I'm in a
[__] dick Mash you I've heard of
those stories though yeah like that yeah
like that kind of [__] going on yeah me
too they're called when guys like each
other
it uh yeah it straddles the line a
little bit but I mean I've heard that
there's a fine line there is I don't
know but it was never a routine thing
where like it's it's Friday shower day
like we're all gonna no but like like
Circle Jerks and [__] like that you know
I've never done it either I mean I'm
just saying I've heard stories I mean
like yeah I heard I heard this that I
thought was was a good mind [__] these
Navy Seals were freezing on this rock
and the waves were crashing over them
and the instructor guy goes first guy
who gets a hard on
if you get if one of you guys can get a
hard-on in this freezing cold you can
[__] get out of here yeah Mission
Impossible now that that now I'm I'm I'm
I'm doing sure I can't if I'm sure to
get a hard on right that's where you use
your mind that's not Hazen no that's
more like a mindset I would be fine
because I'm always hard
oh no we looked down just ahead of his
dishes
[Music]
all right so that guy get fired yeah
two-week suspension but then more kids
came out but then I heard today on the
news that the kid that like started all
this wanted to get him fired so they
don't know how real it is okay the kid
had like a vendetta sure sure that
happens a lot too now yeah that happens
a lot you should cancel cultures like
get them like if you're if you don't get
playing time whatever it is you're gonna
go yeah that's so [__] up they said a
former player and a current player so
whatever that is but if that guy was
beloved it wouldn't stick yeah I mean
they won one game I think I think it
maybe it might be because of your story
that the guy is not that great of a guy
you know maybe that's not to me now
maybe he was having a rough day I was
like 11. is that like the one like like
let's say you're in a bar like obviously
you're a professional fighter you're
trained to not get pissed off at people
like because I'm sure guys come up to
you and want to fight you never never
with the feet if somebody was like yeah
what's up Bigfoot would that [__]
trigger no not at all it takes they'd
have to hit my kid or wife or something
okay you're taking a lot okay a ton okay
okay are you you're not mad at me right
now for a second no not at all big feet
are cool man you know what they say
about big feet right yeah you got a good
size foot on yourself
tiny feet little foot big back huh
big back all right let's just see you
can get a hard on first guys come on
here we go here we go guys all right
here we go
uh so this one real quick so apparently
people notice after the whole you know
Kid Rock protesting against Bud Light
apparently some fans noticed that Kid
Rock's Bars were still selling yeah
Nashville yeah so were they still
selling Bud Light that you saw I don't
know probably yeah but people were
taking pictures of themselves in his bar
yeah so here's one picture here I think
the whole thing's right there
it is silly but yeah I drink my light
and I'll drink Budweiser I don't care
what you guys [__] say exactly if you
don't care what you guys no I don't care
I mean I'd assume you'd suck me off but
sure I will too well I was at the Padres
game I was with my brother and uh my
opener Brett Forte and I don't really
drink beer I don't drink it but they
want beer so I'm like you got some beer
so you're owing on the app and I see
it's like modella cores it's like 1616
but like seven dollars it's like the
price is oh they're dropping it huh so I
ordered the bear the not Bud Light right
well you did because it was cheaper no I
didn't I didn't I didn't want that heat
so when the guy came when the guy came
over I go hey man real quick how long
you've been doing this he's like oh man
30 years oh cool I said has anybody
ordered Bud Light today it was not one
like they're worried about what people
are gonna say or the way they're gonna
look like that's insane I'll just buy
the Bud Light put them in the clear cup
and save money there are some places
there are some places like in the US
like South Carolina where I was just at
Greenville great town have you done
Greenville no great town but it's the
Bible Belt yeah and uh there are some
things that it's a it's still it's still
to a degree like if you just go outside
that town it's a segregated part of the
world yeah yeah and there are certain
things that are like you don't make fun
of certain things you know it's a really
weird thing because it's kind of like
there's an LGBT community there and
that's good yeah yes but overall like if
you start making fun of white people
which sometimes I do in my act now be
careful because you got to make sure
it's couched with other [__] because
they clam up they're just like black MC
was like do you see how tight they got
when he started making fun of black
white people and I was like I know I was
just but with also Butler it's just a
miscalculation like no you're demo dude
it's like me making fun of dudes no your
dad I know you're demo dude I guess so
but who gives a [__] I mean really it's
just [__] beer right and these people
are so like this [__] [__] like
shooting the beer with a machine gun
it's the dumbest [__] thing I've ever
seen
it's a [__] beer who gives a [__]
well I think people are so tired of the
gender ideology not because I guess so
but before him out of the cancel culture
and that's cancel culture yeah isn't
that cancer culture that's economic
boycott that might be a little same
thing it's the same thing yeah it's
still okay under a different name you
can't be you know I get his point but I
I like the reason why people are
triggered because it's when it's forced
it's like dude don't pick a side just
make yeah I would say that I need to
trigger because there's some inside of
them I don't think so it might be gay I
think in this case the gender thing I
think it's very surprising to people
that they that for most Americans the
line that you draw is when you start
trying to indoctrinate children into
your what's called ideology yeah that's
that's a that's a that's a dog whistle
that's a dog whistle but it is not going
but that is not I'm with him on this
like most like transgender and stuff
like that they don't they don't
subscribe to that I agree like that
that's a that's a small minority that's
like saying all people are Italian are
in the mafia your algorithm is lying to
you you're right yeah like most trans
people like what we don't want to dance
in front of kids right but they push and
that's what we're like it's also silly
but it's also dragged out there to make
it right people don't like what's very
interesting about them heavy on the drag
right is that yes but what's funny about
America and all this is like Pride used
to be a thing where you were gay you
were on the outside looking in and it
was like you know it was very hard to be
gay we're gonna have a parade and and
just celebrate survival you know pride
has now been co-opted by every
corporation so you're mainstream and
it's all you've just been enveloped into
the capitalist Market structure it's all
good and I think people see a lot of
these corporations using trans using
this stuff as just a way to sell more
product correct they don't like being
they don't like being Shield to and I do
think that this gender this idea that
for example biological men in women's
sports biological men being able to say
I'm I'm woman and I'm going to a female
president getting two inmates pregnant
like they did in California oh come on
that did happen that did not happen that
happened here in California no way look
it up okay not only that okay and then
saying well I I can be in a women's
locker room as a fully intact male and
my daughter's changing in that now I
that may be rare but but that is what
what happens with people is they go it
may be that those are stories that are
sensationalists which I agree they are
but it's definitely the outlier
but if that becomes see
oh the New York Post oh yeah okay all
right but but it is but it did it did
happen Okay and in Scotland now you have
people with the new law where you can
you can say I'm a woman after three
months you don't have to have anything
you can just have a beard whatever if
you are a woman you are put in a
Scottish prison now there's now a
referendum say hold on if you're a
sexual assault you know if you've
committed a sexual assault you can't do
that what I'm saying is that there is a
gender ideology has has become a an
issue people have to deal with and
parents go wait wait well it's become
people because some people are
amplifying it more than it really exists
I agree 100 I think it's very rare I
don't know anybody who's dealing with it
do you like I don't know I'll tell
anybody who's like anti-gare anti well
I'll tell you this I'll tell you this
one story yeah I want to know what you
think I'll tell this one story is that
my kids play sports my daughter plays my
daughters play lacrosse I remember the
first guy I went to and there was a kid
out there a trans kid whose biological
boy playing in the girls league and I
was like what the [__] scored 60 goals
yeah no didn't score six goes because
they're you know yeah didn't and so I
was like what the [__] and I was furious
and I was furious and I and I went to my
daughters and I was like doesn't that
piss you off like what and I was like
that thing and their their position is
totally different they we look at it as
a fairness thing they don't look at it
that way right they said to me dad
everyone feels like they everyone should
have the chance to belong to something
everyone's had the chance to belong and
that kid how do you play in the cross
should belong how do you feel about Leah
Thomas Leah Thomas is such an outlier
but you know yes and it exists but who
cares
it's the exception that's the one
everyone it's not like every pool you go
to there's uh transgender there are
thousands of kids playing lacrosse and
soccer and whatever NCAA picked it up as
as a an acceptable law that's where it
gets lost so so hold on so let me just
keep going yeah so you have your
daughter who is a biological female yeah
she has worked very hard for her
All-American status this is where we're
into this fairness thing go ahead yes
yeah yeah and by the way there are
scholarships involved in everything else
and a kid in high school who's a
biological male the first three
biological males come along and take
that All-American status and that
doesn't happen but okay but it does not
happen but okay for his exam happened
that one time but my thing with the
lacrosse these are things that Trump up
but that doesn't mean it doesn't bother
me because you know what as a society
we should have a world where people are
comfortable being who they are yeah and
who gives a [__] about uh about who wins
the 14 year old girls lacrosse the girls
do and who [__] the girls they don't
because I've talked to them about it but
but but let me just don't care
would you would you care if that
transgender player that from male to
female let's say she he or whatever he
goes by pronouns let's say he scored 60
goals and gave your daughter a
concussion because he's biologically a
male then would you like hold on here
now just because that person was bad at
lacrosse so you think
but but but Kevin it's gonna but the
problem is it it could open up so you're
saying you're saying biological males if
they identify as females should be
allowed to be in any female sport
uh
this is the this is the problem is that
you you guys think that there are people
out there who are trying to get ahead
and playing in these other sports but
they just want to be a part of a team
like anybody else I think the majority
and they should be I think the majority
of a transgender team no because then
it's separate but equal right isn't that
the same exact thing so so then you
think that being so this is very
important though yeah so you're saying
that you're saying that very rare or a
male is a feeling oh he's great say that
again you're saying that a male or a man
or a woman
is a feeling it's just a feeling right
well I mean I don't know I don't
experience that I have to make but we
but we have to have
standard because if we're going to move
forward with policy at the level of
detail sure okay you have to be able to
Define these things so if you are going
to say that it's a man I I'm a man yeah
you know I'm I'm a 20 year old man I'm
6'4 whatever I am and I'm going to now
get into women swimming and be the
greatest female swimmer and be
recognized for it which is what happened
with Leah Thomas who by the way is a
fully intact male and was in the locker
room with those women okay okay fully
intact they did not feel comfortable I
don't know that's the case but okay that
is the case I don't know that's the case
but it is because I followed it you were
in the locker room with them no I've
listened to Rowdy Gaines and the other
people talk about it okay the other
women were were Rowdy games the woman
who yes and she's she was the best
swimmer in the country I guess and she
not I guess Kev you're saying I guess no
no I'm saying I'm saying I don't really
hold much stock in what she says why she
she was the best swimmer in the country
well because she worked really hard to
be that so you're saying that and by the
way she tied and they gave Leah Thomas
to award you know why because she's a
she's a well but be real quick Leah
Thomas was ranked what when she was a
man 435 when she right now as a female
number one
that's not fair that's a problem but see
that's my point is you're worried about
fairness
you know I'm worried about no no no but
then you should play sports
I mean actually plan a team and have I
mean that's the but we say because Kev
baseball today right you can't do
baseball yeah what's the coach the first
thing they say it doesn't matter if we
win or lose let's just have a good time
right and now you say that's [__]
but that's what they say every day every
day for those kids and those kids should
have that experience too they should
have that experience yes but we should
also have something called fairness men
can I give you I know but that's my
point great you're looking at it from
this perspective of fairness and then
these people don't look at it yes they
do women are they don't women for the
vast majority of females athletes and
mothers in this country vast majority
well over 75 that's this is the stat let
me just give you some stats well over 75
but it might be 85 disagree with you how
do you where do you get your stats how
do you know they take these polls that
Kevin and where'd they take it
I meet are like shocked that that men
are all of a sudden trying to protect
the women's sports there are tons of
problems with women's sports tons of
them and the first one and the top 10 of
them are have nothing to do with
transgender so let's go back to this
right so again you think that a man or a
woman is a feeling so it's just a
declaration and if it is a day I didn't
say that okay but I didn't say that what
are you saying because we have to come
to a see I'm saying that I have nothing
against trans people I'm saying when I
don't even know what it means to be
transparent I couldn't even experience
it and neither can you you don't know
what it most Americans
athletes and sports look you don't know
look at this look at this we've had most
of them we've had this conversation this
is this is so many times
Kevin every poll but it doesn't matter
forget it absolutely forget that Paul
what I'm trying to say is like okay
that's not relevant what I object to is
this we have to at least come to a
conclusion yeah at the level of detail
to run policy that's fine it does matter
fairness does matter so really that
conclusion should come to the point
where we don't [__] on people for who
they are what about yes they are they're
vilified these people are being vilified
there's no question about it I think I
think Leah Thomas is a grifter
I really think that she did it to be
number one yes I do see that's the
difference that's right I don't believe
that and you think she did Justice she
did it because she so she should be sure
she's the best female swimmer in the
world women swimmer you you say really I
don't know that's semantics it's not
semantics when it is
I know I don't even who can't like no
but there's the point I know but you're
gonna create rules yes and vilify people
we have rules because you want to figure
out what's fair to you right no no but
they don't look at that we have rules my
and the rules are that we have when
women's and men's sports for a very
specific reason is that I'll give it to
you okay the best 15 year old and under
soccer players in the country yeah beat
the U.S national women's team five to
nothing 15 and under boys do you know
that story I don't okay but that is the
that is the that is the discrepancy
physically between men and women and
that's just a fact yes that's fine so
when you when you come in there and take
a woman's Olympic silver medal gold
medal bronze medal away because you are
and who's seven inches taller who did
that when you are how much stronger well
what metal has been taken away who did
it you know me and Tom's been taking a
minute Living Well for anybody no she
took an NCAA Championship and second
place and she changed the whole race
because she decided all of a sudden that
she was a woman
what's her name Rowdy game Riley gains
yeah right if she came up to that Podium
and she said you know what I get it I
get it you guys are upset and I'm upset
too
but the reality is I'm confident in my
abilities and the skills and what I've
done in my life and I'm proud to live in
a country I'm proud to live in a country
and be part of an organization
that is inclusive and that helps people
feel like they belong to something and
they're very comfortable with who they
are we're very inclusive no we're not
be comfortable who we are if she said
that I'd wear a [__] t-shirt but she
didn't she went around the country like
you know sponsored by turning point or
these [__] places are yeah yeah she
actually absolutely did common sense and
fairness no you know she sounds Petty
she sounds Petty Kevin she's she's stack
of sacrificed her whole life to be the
best let me ask you this would you have
a problem like I know you it's all like
did you have fun though right but it's
also what if more transgenders start
going into female sports and then now
it's not just Leah Thompson now one
through five are placing that were
formerly men now they're female right
identified as female you got to do
something and then women cannot compete
sure but that's what's gonna happen
they're not gonna be like a computer I
don't think that's gonna happen I know
it's coming but that's the slippery
slope of argument right that's a
slippery
but if you open that door and then men
are like hold up the memory maybe we
figured out what the situation is then
but I don't know that's going to happen
do you think though that there is that
we should have in conversation around
the definitions of a man and a woman and
should those include biology or should
they just include the idea that I say
this so I should be included because if
you're really sure they should include
biology okay but that's what I'm saying
is that we have to figure that's what I
object to yeah when when a new gender
ideology comes along and says by the way
I'm a woman I've decided and you have to
acknowledge that that is a religious
point of view right so the idea is don't
dead name me because I have a new birth
I'm I'm reborn it's very similar to
actually it's very similar to
Christianity I guess but but I I feel
like what you're doing is trivializing
that decision and that announcement and
I think people struggle with that for a
very long time at some point yeah
because you're I think you're saying
like hey I've just decided I'm just
going to be a woman that's I've just
decided that but I think people struggle
with that for a long course they do it's
a very real and it's a very hard thing
especially with the animosity that goes
with it well you're you're what you're
doing is saying hey there are people who
have real gender dysphoria and they kill
themselves as a result correct suicide
so you're you're coming from this from a
very compassionate inclusive way and God
bless yes I'm not arguing that you're
wrong in that respect but then you don't
have the same compassionate when it
comes to the sports you're like yeah as
long as they're being able to
participants
I don't think it's equal I think oh so
you think the inclusion I think whoever
I think the inclusion in our society is
more important than whoever wins the 15
years old another question let me ask
you a question that's what I believe
Kevin let me ask you and we have to
sacrifice one for the other sometimes
okay so then so then whatever I say
there's a lot of games yeah we might we
might but who cares but why can't what
Brian was saying why can't why can't I
would
you know what if I said I was black and
I want you to treat me like I'm black
and I want benefits as a black person
are you gonna use the Edward I want to
be able to do it all what would you say
then because that's a feeling I think
that's not the same thing it why tell me
why logically logically why well because
well first of all I don't think that we
understand it's possible that I have
some black in me then I'd be intersex
right sure so you can do your 23andMe my
friends 18 African-American but he looks
Italian as [__] right I think it's Frank
Grillo now Frank could say by the way I
actually have some African-American I'm
sub-Saharan African and I want you to
treat me as black what so so we what
about that I don't think it's the same
thing why well I don't think that
there's a um that same struggle I don't
think there's an internal struggle of
trying to figure out you know who you
are I know how to solve this problem
let's get a pull-up bar and let's see
what the [__] happens
but you know what I'm saying though you
don't you don't see that there's I don't
think there's a lot I don't think it was
your equivalent situations why I'm sorry
I think gender but if you're running a
society don't you think you have to
don't you think you have to come to that
conclusion if we're running a society
yeah
so but I think whatever role I make
would go more towards the inclusiveness
as opposed to the fairness which I think
we're different there okay so yeah but
don't you you have to have fairness in
sports right but you're saying sport
we'd rather feel comfortable than win a
game I guess so but being fair is
inclusive right so isn't being fair fair
and inclusion are absolutely
lockstep shoulder to shoulder I don't
know that they are so so I would say
this to be inclusive like I want to be
included in this yeah if you exclude me
it's unfair right so if I'm over here
I'm unfair I think when you introduce
someone who has a physical Advantage
because that they were born with because
they are males and it's a physical
activity it seems to me that that
person's presence is rather exclusionary
to the entire field that has been
practiced by that that way so then
LeBron James
I'm not LeBron James should be able to
join the WNBA and Score 1 000 points do
you understand I know I'm using it but
that's not that's not that's not a real
situation but it but it but when you're
heading I don't know you extrapolate I
don't know what if we do though right so
yeah we'll deal with that when it
happens but we don't we're dealing with
it now Leah Thompson Classic example
that's one
one and there was a great deal of of
activity to make sure it happened a lot
but I think if enough people come out
like transgender come out they can have
their own league right would that be
okay
I don't know I don't know I mean I'm not
transgender so I don't know I think what
it is is you just feel like the it's
interesting because you you are you hold
inclusion to be the highest in the
highest regard I and when it comes to
schools well I I think it's an
individual perception of what fairness
is right you know and I think that's
different from people that's person to
person yeah I think I think at High
Level Sports especially at the
Collegiate level when you're talking
about champions in NCAA that the
fairness it there has to be fear they
all have to start from even in high
school I mean High School sure but
you're talking about major consequences
in in college level oh God yeah you're
talking about scholarships you're
talking about and also
you know taking the one example rolling
down the field has gaining moss and then
Moss really isn't there like it's
there's a fear of this problem that I
don't think it exists I think it exists
but not the level of the anxiety you
have of it
it's not that I have the anxiety over it
it's what I think we're going down a
slippery slope I'm not anxious I'm not
anxious about the individuals I I get
anxious about the actual mindset and
ideology that goes along with it and
that ideology is not logical because
it's impossible because what you are
then saying is that how someone feels
well you're doing two things you're
doing two things you're putting a
definition that may not be the right
definition we are getting rid of
category but you're talking about the
the gender situation being about someone
how they feel or whatever I mean I I
can't speak to that neither can you I
can't how you have an experience because
we because society's ordered a long
gender there are gender lines right so
should we get rid of some people would
argue there aren't so should we get rid
of the idea should we get rid of
pronouns altogether well the problem is
another thing you guys get so hooked up
you guys I'm sorry I don't mean to say
that but people know
until I was I was forced to say my
pronoun I don't give a give a [__] I
mean like yeah whatever you want to call
I don't care about pronouns right you
know call yourself whatever you want to
be called I care if you get upset at me
if I if I met like I'm just supposed to
know yourself yeah but you're that's the
same with someone getting upset at
something stupid everyone
should be men's and women's sports
should there be men's yes there should
yes why
because I think predominantly that's the
situation okay but I mean what I'm
trying to say and I agree but but what
I'm saying is that it it there's a
there's a demarcation there right there
is a there are man and male and female
sports there are men and women right
yeah and why is that probably because it
made we know what it says yeah it's more
that's right so when you uh Serena
Williams said I don't want to play you
Andy Murray you've crush me it's the
best tennis player she I think Serena
said the number 500 tennis player of the
men's tennis player yeah the 300 played
and so so so that's why we have I love
watching tennis right so I'm watching
Wimbledon now I love watching the women
just as much as I love watching the men
I love watching female MMA fighters
pretty much just as much as I love
watching yeah I really do because I
think sometimes the skill level I don't
in a lot of these but but the skill
level in a lot of sports is really
similar they're just not as strong fast
all that stuff but but I enjoy watching
them because I like watching the
competition I like the ferocity of
competition I I root for a certain
players we got it right yeah that is
probably why because the the playing
field becomes more competitive and and
fairer frankly yeah right and so to
introduce a man
who is
inconsequential in the mail field at a
thousand yeah comes in and wins you
don't see a problem with that uh it may
be a problem but I'm that's that's an
outlier yeah right and the reality is
the way I look at it is we love playing
sports we all do right we've played
sports right and we do it partly because
of the camaraderie and to be a part of
something and to be a part of a team and
people should have that opportunity and
I think that the I I think it's a if you
are in frequent situation then what
you're talking about it's just an
infrequent thing where it doesn't really
affect the world or us as opposed to
vilifying a group of people who just
want to be a part of society and part of
to belong to something and I think that
feeling is more important than every
kind of permutation you can think of of
a slippery slope of how it undermines
our world somehow you know what I mean
she she won the swimming thing who gives
a [__] he couldn't have named 10
swimmers before she did it and I know I
know it's offensive to the people who
maybe in your mind should have that
position but if I like I said if I was
that person I'd be like you know what
I believe in inclusivity and I believe
that this person feel like they should
belong
and I will make that sacrificed right
that's what Jesus Christ did you'll make
that isn't that what Jesus Christ did
yes I like I like I love your generosity
of spirit yeah right I think I think and
I I understand where it's coming from
it's it's that I I start to go hold on
now I you cannot run a side of that way
without defining certain things
you can't with that I mean look at LA's
doing that we're crushing it so so yeah
right so so children so because what
happens Kev is it goes into it goes it
really does bleed into children it
really does now you start calling you
start calling irreparable irreparable
surgeries
irreparable drugs
that cause again
so then if that's a boogie man please
tell me why the Tavistock clinic in
England has over a thousand lawsuits
yeah they a thousand lawsuits
shut down
Starship Troopers yeah you know what I'm
saying
we've got to have these conversations
and Define those things otherwise what
happens is it becomes I guess I guess my
thing is I think as a parent I have a
baby girl on the way if she was the one
that Leah Thompson beat I would be Fury
right now I would and I'd like that
feeling yeah I'd be on Fox I don't know
if she would have that feeling she might
not well my daughter oh [__] otherwise
you're not gonna eat
it's too bad but it's also
understandable totally understandable
totally understandable you know well
you're saying it's an outlier there
shouldn't be that much up I don't think
yeah I think it's kind of an outlier and
you know what if I were those girls I
don't know I feel like I would I would
say
steroids say you know you understand
what this person is going through and
you want to be supportive well they did
and by the way they also knew it I think
that's they're also told if they speak
up that they would be fine who told them
by the by the NCAA swimming I think I'd
be surprised and they all said that and
if you're so surprised by it why was
Riley Gaines and you can see it on video
you can just bring it up why was she not
able to get out of her [__] classroom
when those activists wouldn't let her
out and they were screaming at her well
these people are all I've heard
different reviews of that I heard
someone had a pan on her shoulder have
you seen the video yeah I've seen it I
guess what it's nice for me is I think
there's some people that actually it's a
very small percentage so one percent of
the population in North America the
world I don't know but in North America
one percent I think some people are
actually born in the wrong body and they
have it must be awful I can't imagine
yeah and I think there's some people
where it's it could be a mental health
thing where they feel like they need the
surgery they get the surgery we've seen
people that get the surgery they're more
suicidal or they maybe they made a
mistake yeah I think that that's where
you can never enjoy sex that's where
lines get blurred you know yes but I
think there's some people it must be
awful I can't imagine yeah yeah sure and
then there's somewhere it's just like
you just confused at 12. yeah I mean I
don't think there's any kind of blanket
statement about it you know it affects
people the same way or whatever it is so
I I don't disagree like I I think we get
muddled up with the ideas like you don't
want to make fun of somebody for being
you know no like I don't either and I
don't want them to feel and they're a
group they are a group people despite
their group people who
uh have been vilified and they're
misunderstood yes yes and they don't
have a lot of Champions I'm not into
that yeah yeah you know I don't want to
hurt somebody's like we all we've had
we've had transgender people on this
podcast yes we have who Warrior Princess
the Navy SEAL oh yeah Kristen back there
you know I mean don't be don't act like
it's like if once a week yeah but but
I've had one Navy
worked out with somebody who was a who
was a fully fully transitioned yeah so
this guy who's trying to not sound
racist I have a black friend
no that died a copy Jenner dysphoria
whatever you want to call it exists and
the suicide rate is higher it's so so
here's a stat for you just to back I
have another transgender people kill
themselves almost out of 40 I think it's
47 but 42 between 42 and 47. now that's
terrible right you know even in slavery
back in slavery like in the United
States this the suicide rate wasn't that
high so the only people that have the
same suicide or paranoid schizophrenics
so it's a [__] terrible thing so if
you have a child that kills themselves
because they're transgender this is
where the passion comes in because
people are like how do we stop this well
you're saying they kill himself because
they're transgender or because they're
denying who they are I think it's it's
because they were born the wrong body
and and unfortunately I'm just saying
your status is in favor of what is that
is that well no I understand that I
understand I try to protect them got it
I understand the understanding to storm
the cap no I understand you saying hey
man I like we need like why not be
inclusive like I get it yeah I just
think
I think it's worth going about it the
wrong way
going about being includes the wrong way
yeah yeah I do I think we're going about
it and I think I don't think it's
even a fraction of as big as a problem
in our success
I agree with that yeah I think you're
right I think it makes a fortune the
news makes a Fortune of taking these
these extreme examples and your
algorithm lies yes you know this guy am
I right no I just worry about him I'm
glad he stuck it to you I know I don't
know that I did Stick it to you but I
mean boy we want a little tangent though
didn't we oh boy I enjoyed it you've
said zero words yeah and I appreciate
that but I've never had a copy
conversation I've never had anybody
defend it like that I live for this
conflict so Kevin is a lawyer in two
states are you I am yeah you're a lawyer
yeah ah you [__] you have your law
degree I do get the [__] out of here he
represented the apartment I'm fighting
the [__] representative [__]
he's I'll tell you what I would have
done what cases do you what do you what
do you uh study uh I I graduated from
law school right and then we started
making movies
law school I went to Brooklyn law school
you [__] you lawyer he's a smart
[__] dude I'm getting hustled over
here I've had these conversations with
them several times it's tough to win
right well you know what there is no
winning that's the thing there is he's
aware yeah and lawyers focus on the
[__] Ally
no but it's you know it's interesting
though because it's like it is as a as a
professional debater
you realize that there are like there
are times where it's like there's no
[__] point in having this
conversation because whatever you say
there's going to be another yeah we
arrived at a conclusion I don't know
you read that completely I think
inclusion is more important than
fairness and he's not American he's also
an American yeah so we know he's a
communist very American yeah and I drink
[__] Budweiser too like an American
like a like a Bud Light Americans drink
Bud lighter I think uh Dylan mulvania
that transgender woman is is trolling
everybody anyway well announcer but now
but she's pissed right she's pissed at
Bud Light because they didn't stick by
her right I think Bud Light needs to
lean into and just go gay or
if I'm them I really lean in that was
The Farley wasn't that Farley gay was
that Farley yeah thing yeah they
remember their big commercial when I was
a kid was like
yeah they could redo that like yeah yeah
that's great
so funny I'm offended if I'm but I just
lean into it like they sponsored the gay
pride thing yeah and people like that's
ridiculous I'm like no they're doing
exactly what they should do like at
least have some audience well that
definitely the the market got moved a
little bit on them I guess so I know
maybe that's part of the problem yeah
yeah I don't know three billion yeah
people took that that they they have not
recovered no right it keeps yeah no but
they will yeah this is Budweiser bro
yeah the king of beers yeah a little
time out he'll be fine Americans
Americans really just Americans can't
hold the attention span American to life
remember like the hole in the ozone
layer or a layer or [__] acid rain
we're like sure I don't know if I can
announce we just forget about [__] it
just goes away it just depends or or it
ruins them like sometimes it can ruin
companies it'll ruin yeah well
Budweiser's not going anywhere they'll
be all right people are like you drink
them I drink Bud water people are like
this I love you got a Budweiser beer can
on ice is one of the finest but would
you drink it I like a Padres game
there's like a bunch of people around
yeah really yeah mostly like I was I was
doing shows in Covina and uh there's
these guys and they were like hey man
can you get a picture on their arms are
like this I'm like what's behind your
back like I was like what's going on and
I thought they're gonna shoot me and the
guy's like no no and they bring their
Bud Lights that's all they had I'm like
I don't give a [__] on it you're gay but
I don't give a [__] yeah and they're
like can we take the picture off the Bud
Light I'm like you guys care I'm like oh
yeah but you don't drink beer you don't
care uh are you a beer guy I wouldn't
order Bud Light yeah no but just because
because you don't like Bud lighter just
because you know I don't like when they
push it down my throat like it all
tastes same to me I don't really care
okay okay I like Peroni
on my other show golden hour and uh he's
like in the barracks like he's a Marines
getting shipped over and I I said hey
real quick man uh is there Bud Light on
like the premise he's like no no no no
and he's like oh no man we don't play
that [__] I'm like well hold on you
won't drink Bud Light he's like no not
at all I'm like why though like it's
just that's not crazy
I was like yeah that's crazy because
it's like I I find that see my version
of that is I love uh my bidets I love my
[__] bidets [__] great but there
is a whole chunk of dudes who are like
that's gay I'm like what is gay about a
bidet and they're like putting something
in your [__] and like do so you have
a a dirty [__] [__] homophobe yeah
you still there yeah I have the [__]
most spotless [__] on this planet
yeah it is weird what hill they died
well you know I was like man that's gay
turn on the UFC let's watch these guys
you know it's like all right I do think
that we are all [__] being told look
over here when the big problems are over
here right so to your to like like when
we're divisive
[__] now the culture wars between
right wing and left-wing Republican
Democrats is about things like this it's
about like uh [__] transgender [__]
right or Bud Light don't say gay and
stuff like that yeah when like inflation
yes and the the big things like the real
money
right the amount of money we're spending
and what kind of Statistics are on some
that's what actually matters yeah and
how much we're actually spending tickets
entitlements yeah but that's not sexy
man no no literally all of us are
talking about Leah Thomas when we should
be talking about [__] no we say all
this you well he's a lawyer
we talked about it we just talked about
it I'm saying we came to Common Ground
no he doesn't believe that girls should
have sports
[Laughter]
you guys like the days I love them yes I
drank it when I was a kid I thought it
was a water fountain really my uncle had
one I've never seen him like this is
sick a lot of Fountain by the toilet do
you have one in your house either of you
guys no I I wash my ass in the sink
not restaurants I've seen it it's
disgusting I mean don't say restaurants
but you've done it before your wife sent
me a picture of you doing it in a
restaurant and I've been in multiple
home I've been in multiple rooms I live
in a restaurant but like your pants are
down by the sink and yeah and he's going
just give me a second to open the door
I'm like this all right and I gotta go
eat finger food did I stick my ass in
the sink right in front of you yeah dude
I enjoyed it we're close
I would have a bidet I enjoy them when
people have one of mys oh damn look at
you I have three in my house slight Flex
dude you're three I do is it the toilet
or did you add on to no no he had to put
in his trailer on the set he had the
teams just put let me just say [__]
let me just say today in his trailer you
want to know you asked me like yes I'll
drink a Bud Light I went up to the
[__] most hairy tattooed [__]
Teamster
in season two because the president
Network sent sent us bidets really well
because he and I were we were at dinner
we were talking about that were
sensitive anus people and he was like
have you tried a bidet I'm like no and
he's like I'm I'm ascending what's a
sense of anus person like if I like on
Sundays if I've taken like three poops
or something like that my butthole gets
irritated yeah I mean sometimes my
underwear at night man I'm like wow
because then I'm in that category yeah
exactly maybe you should get him a day
bro yeah I gotta get that Tacoma money
dude yeah well you know so so I went up
to the [__] Teamster this guy is
definitely like you know the Hell's
Angel probably yeah and I was like I
know you hear some [__] ass actor [__]
and this is gonna be pussier and more
actory than anything you've ever heard
but will you please install a bidet in
my trailer and he [__] laughed at me
that is the [__] pussiest [__] I've
ever [__] heard of my life and he
went and did it and then we did an
episode about my character getting a
bidet in Tacoma FD season three started
that Teamster came up to me he's like
brother
I went and finally got a [__] bidet
that [__] I live by that [__] that is
the [__] because of you I got that
[__] day keeps your [__] clean
that's how it starts otherwise you got
[__] in your back you know well then I
tell people you can clean your house all
the ways I mean you know no see there's
a traditional way
no no he's a number here's what I don't
like what the bidet this is my problem
with it was that it's not inclusive it's
not inclusive well it's not there
there's no hot water setting on the one
that we had right so it's cold water
cold water shooting your [__] because
you can get the hot one yes but Europe
the days are like everywhere yeah but so
like the cold thing is like like to me
that's a [__] wake up pick me up in
the morning that's better than a shot of
espresso it's like a nice cold ice cold
yeah it just it just sprays everywhere
though like it's it is a mess right well
it's wet yeah
that's going down
that way you can clean it this Ryan
takes the one and splashes it I don't
Splash it that's not how I do it you go
like this do you put your finger you
don't know how I clean my [__] do you
put your finger in your [__] to clean
it I sure don't you mean do I go like
this
he sits on his fingers no I what I'm
saying is that if you are uh baking a
cake yeah and you've got your frosting
tube yeah and frosty put the frosting on
the cake and then you wipe you wash that
nozzle you wipe it clean everything
there's still frosting inside the nozzle
I suck it up well I don't know what
you're eating I don't know what you're
eating a lot of pizza loaf I'm clean uh
you know so you think
so you think hey man this is getting
crazy out of dirty [__] oh damn it I
think it's clean but it's dirty on the
inside because because I'm a [__]
Master uh but Damon and I will I'll sit
there for like 20 extra minutes and fire
the I'll fire it up get it up there my
butt until my butt has no more room and
sprays it back out and stuff comes out
you're a gay guy like what comes out
he's a super bottom or like like food
carrots and corn everything like you
know like like um
like films you know like like layers
that were like oh you might need those
man you think it sounds like you're too
high up in there yeah but I heard it had
a skid mark in five years that's what
makes me jump and I haven't had an itch
oh my underwear you don't clean your
[__] I tried my best you're you're
the worst I mean he'll sit on a [__]
public John with he's just like [__] I
don't know and he's just like oh she
wipes it twice that's why I tell my wife
when she kept buying white underwear I'm
like what are you doing you know me dark
colors camouflage is best
you get [__] colored underwear do you
get brown on brown stuff to find are you
a blind Wiper like will you just wipe
and and no I'll look I'm like man this
is a nightmare because I've met now I'm
like I gotta get out of here have you
ever met a person that doesn't look like
an hour would you say have you ever met
a person that doesn't know I've never I
feel like I have I've you definitely
have yeah we know a guy you no not me
I have to eat off his ass
[Laughter]
yeah oh
uh The Undertaker whoa and his wife
Michelle McCool found a shark I like
that he's protecting her what do you do
you punch it the tombstone powder oh
he's he's between them right now
but maybe if she just got out of the
water it wouldn't be a problem oh he's
staring it down she's on a boat that's a
lemon shark
oh no she's she's on the street they can
just walk out of the water I don't find
this to be a very threatening situation
yeah I've read that you [__] rescued
somebody from like a burning vehicle
yeah no right off the 101.
that's [__] here yep
that's like real I saw the video yeah it
was intense super intense and I I've
been some like high trauma stuff and I
was supposed to go to this uh double
date dinner I still show up to dinner
and I was just like you're like are you
okay and I had blood on my shirt and
they're like what is what the [__]
happened I was like I should probably I
was like I should probably go yeah and I
left yeah were you were you a little
[__] up
you had glasses oh really oh you saw bad
[__] yeah yeah but but but they the cops
um brought him in to be a witness to
this because the guy tried to kill his
family and uh you said that it was
amazing everything was on video like
everything oh man they brought me in the
the California uh Highway Patrol brought
me in to cooperate the story right so
and I'm going through everything to
write it down write it down and then uh
he's like as a promise okay TMZ's
calling and he's like and you know
sometimes celebrities I was like I'm not
celebrating like sometimes celebrities
will make things up so the news gets out
there I'm like I don't want this going
anywhere man like that's not how I did
it I'll give myself and get out of here
and so I tell them like all right cool
man yeah checks out I'm like yeah no
[__] so I'm leaving he's like you want
to see something and they show up on the
lap they have a laptop and there's
cameras all over the 101 all over the
highways
so he had it so I because I was going to
do a nice dinner site on these tight
jeans and Gucci boots is because that
you you see my porch go flying by the
accident happens and you see me running
in my tight jeans look at that you I'm
like I think so they see me running
through gasoline because it they it was
a gasoline truck that the father ran
into trying to commit suicide with him
and his family oh my God and he gets out
of the car nice kids in the car kids in
the car how old life died uh there's
four kids or three kids in the car like
I think the oldest probably nine or ten
oh Jesus nine or ten and then the I was
running through gas and I remember just
all this strong gasoline smell and then
when I got to the car the you know mom's
gone but that I didn't know what was
going on and I thought
they just got hit and I see this guy
running like this like chubby or like
Mexican Father Peter the father run away
from the scene I'm like where the [__]
is he going but he's going down the 101
and then a car goes boom hits him I see
him boom fall I'm like well he's dead
I'm gonna get these kids and I look over
and he pops up like a night stock like
the White Walker yeah she's like gets up
and keeps running I'm like what the [__]
is he why was he doing that because he
tried to the family yeah then I got the
kids out handed off I was like I want
nothing to do with jump back my car I go
to dinner
said they're like man we wish you would
have stayed because that Dad came back
around and he was trying to do like
death by police suicide by police he was
like trying to fight us like we'd love
for you to put on a show for us we came
back I'm like boy would I ever if I knew
he was trying to kill his kids I would
give you guys a show okay pull his head
off his spine yeah that was really
[__] horrible oh dude
and the kid was so young like his
mommy's like I want my mom and I I'm
like where's your mom he's like she's in
the front I go to look and yeah the
mom's you know Bad Bad Brains like oh
don't look I'm trying to ask him his
favorite like Disney movie oh man so I
hand to the lady and she's like I'll
take him this way I'm like don't go that
way go that way she's like why I'm like
I don't want to see his mom yeah it's
gonna affect the rest of Life go that
way yeah yeah but I'm still in
communication with so the kids went with
their aunt and that we raised a bunch of
money for their GoFundMe and the kids
are doing better now okay yeah what a
horrible thing Jesus yeah those are
tough oh man horrible man so good for
you though man [__] hero I was
driving the gasoline truck how do you
think I finished son of a [__] you know
what I did there see what I did there
give me the guy coming down the road
that was you that's a vehicle putter
right there that's a treat
why is this podcast so heavy what the
[__] going on guys we've really
covered it [__] really oh we covered
it was like
yeah and I was just arguing for America
okay you're right you're right how bad
was that an Undertaker video
let's just be honest what's he just do
you just stand there looking he was just
like this why it's like I am so scared
right now thank God my knight in shining
armor yeah do you think that shark was
like oh my gosh
you guys from the dead I don't want to
[__] with him yeah
here's a quick one real quick because
Jamie Foxx has been out of the news for
a while people have no idea what's going
on with him but he was in public on a
boat
I'm on a baby
there he is he looks fine oh
everyone said like his face was gonna
mess up he seems all right yeah it was
awesome
we don't know the fact right no one
knows anything about it yeah Topgolf
yeah
playing golf
I thought he was going he was partially
blind yeah we've heard all sorts it
looks good and then his daughter came
out because the news ran with the doctor
came out I was like that's not it was
just with him yesterday he's fine it
looks good but that's so sweet [__]
though no he was in the hospital for a
long time and what is known about he had
a stroke
he got the shot and that led to his
stroke oh oh that's the rumor but who
knows what's real right and then
obviously the media runs with her like
yeah he's never gonna be the same and
then here he is on a [__] yacht with
hoes and stuff doing his thing seems
like he's all right you guys ever worked
with him no no
so I've seen him around like he um
he lives over yeah yeah I've seen him
around yeah but he's great
that guy's so [__] talented oh man
did you work might be the most time I've
spent a little time with him yeah a
couple times and he's great such a great
guy but I'm such a fan oh yeah because
unbelievably town it's like the black
Ryan count
it's not
it's not it is annoying when they
compare you guys I'm better at whipping
sports like if I have to play tennis
where you whip your body or you you know
but uh but in in straight
Power Sports he's better he's got more
power what's this
so a Georgian mayor he saw a house on a
lake he thought it was his he was like
this is my dream house he approached it
the homeowner held him at gunpoint until
the police arrived uh he responded to
this with Yellen you know who the f I am
and wasn't very happy I don't blame and
were the police uh in the force of the
town that he was the mayor in or it was
a different town it's the same time
Kevin you could represent him because
this is a classic example of racial
profiling this is where being black is
different than being white where people
are like I get arrested for looking at a
house and the guy was like no he broke
in the house bro
yeah so his thing his Alibi was [__]
cut he thought he broke into a house
the guy's like this is my house like
this LeBron wait wait he broken I
thought he was looking at the house
he thought it was an abandoned house so
that's the thing I don't know if he
broke in or not but he was in this
person and the guy yelled at him several
times and he replies do you know who the
[__] I am
and then I'm the mayor I'll wait for my
police to get here and see what happens
and they arrested his dumbass and then
he apologized to the police [__] up
yeah that's what I'm thinking oh that's
interesting previous hot water for
spending a thousand dollars of
government money on a tick tock uh-oh
celebrate the fifth year that's the
house
looks a little run down to me yeah a lot
of drink I think I think you're always
in trouble and I you know maybe you guys
have done this before I don't know yeah
but
when you say do you know who I am that's
right that's always a thing that's an
issue that's always you know you're in
the wrong place yeah you know what I
mean it's also not good to do you know
who I am so it's not good too break into
a house I don't know that's not yours is
what I'm saying sure I like that Brian
was like there's no problem with America
Man Poor black guy he's like what the
[__] are you talking about dude
he's the [__] guy wants to be
inclusive I guess bi people should be
allowed to break it down I think my more
moderate than that you know that's okay
he's a little more moderate yeah
the marriage
so he knows that's a crime as long as
he's a wrong law is that it chin That's
it man wow do you guys have stuff to
plug
awkward it's been such a heavy [__]
day I know
[Laughter]
my mom died right I didn't know I I just
yes Steve you brought that in mind
you're having fun about the days you're
like yeah this is fun hey you saw a dead
lady right I didn't know any of that to
me in my mind you were like [__] in
slow motion running with like no that's
if I told a story yeah and that's that
because I lost your back
no I picked her up and uh revived her
yeah
let's see Tacoma FD
premieres uh July 20th July 20th season
14. True TV on True TV with Encore
broadcast on TBS and then the first
three seasons are on uh Max counts
yawning in the middle oh my God I'm so
sorry yeah I'm so sorry Super Troopers
you're some of my favorites Justice yeah
we love you guys thank you thanks guys
awesome thank you
um you I was bombed you were you were
[__] killing me on schooled so we had
a good time we did a good time yeah we
had a good time that was fun yeah we got
canceled there I am Blue Room Missouri
are you plugging sorry I'll be there uh
Friday July 21st July 22nd and then I'm
at the Ontario I'm such a great day 28
29th look at that the upper right one
what are you what joke are you telling
there
something shitty
bird God
that looks like the hackiest I look like
the hackiest [__] who's doing my
pictures
you are you doing yourself or no you got
somebody yeah I got somebody you got a
person doing that yeah look at that way
look at this shot though look at this
this is a [__] good looking shot
right here what's up yeah look at that
what's up I just watched the um the Wham
documentary on Netflix which one wham
wham it's uh where's Michael yeah George
Michael yeah no that's uh that's not
it's called Culture Club what is wham is
uh Wham is George Michael Careless
Whispers yeah yeah
no that's Culture Club wake me up before
I go go wake me up before I go yeah
it's great if you you know if you like
win but the but the real thing is that
like George Michaels is always like well
lit like that looking good like there's
good hair good [__] like good hair
y'all gotcha anyway so that's the Laugh
Factory lighting though look at that
good hair though I'll take it man good
hair dude uh I get a bunch of tour dates
coming up uh in August to be announced
by the end of this week next one around
I'm at the Lafayette Thursday night I'm
sorry I'm at The Comedy Store Thursday
night Laugh Factory I think Friday
Saturday doing spots in La shopping
friends at Pasadena Ice House July 28th
8 P.M show I think Spokane's on there
skank Fest Vegas Niagara Falls but we
got a bunch coming up so stay tuned
Spokane goes to Tacoma you should go see
the firehouse well Ken I think yeah I
think the same guy
on both clubs do you shoot any stock
footage in Tacoma or no no no I mean
people get mad that we should but you
know it costs that costs money man yeah
yeah like go shoot something you can get
that stuff off the internet man
yeah oh yeah Google to call me we love
you guys man thanks for coming thanks
guys thank you guys thank you